[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi.
And welcome to a very special
episode of the Google Cloud
Platform Podcast.
I am Mark Mandel.
And I'm here with my
colleague, Melanie Warrick.
MELANIE WARRICK: Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hello, Melanie.
How are you doing?
MELANIE WARRICK: It's like
our after-school special.
MARK MANDEL: It is our
after-school special.
Yes, you convinced me
to do a midweek episode.
MELANIE WARRICK: I did.
There was some news that broke
in the last couple of weeks
around the CPU vulnerabilities,
sometimes known as or known
as Meltdown and Spectre.
And so we were able to get
in touch with the security
guys on our end who had
provided some great content
around blog posts
that are out there
and how it's impacted GCP.
So we got them on the
podcast so that they
could talk about
the blog and give us
some additional insight.
And we're going to go
ahead and jump straight
into that for everybody.
We're going to skip our
cool things of the week.
We're going to skip the
question at the end.
Because we are focused
mostly on making sure
that we provide this information
out for everybody to have
access to.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Let's go talk to Matt and Paul.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right,
on this week's podcast,
we have some of our
security experts joining us.
We have Matt Linton, who
is our Chaos Specialist.
And we have Paul Turner,
who a software engineer.
And we are going to talk about
the CPU vulnerabilities that
were discussed in
the last couple weeks
and had some good
content that has come out
around how to protect yourself.
So before we dive into
that a little bit,
can you guys tell us a
little more about who you are
and what you do?
PAUL TURNER: My name is Paul.
And I work on the operating
system and kernel team here.
I was involved from
a fairly early point
in resolving this vulnerability,
trying to find mitigations,
ways to improve the
problem, and how
to do it in a way that
really had a minimal impact.
MATT LINTON: And my name's Matt.
I'm an incident manager on
Google's Security and Privacy
Team.
My team is the 24-hour
escalation point
for suspected security
issues and other things that
urgently need security
engineers' attention.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great
Great, thank you.
So I know you both
co-wrote a blog
post that was helping to outline
what these vulnerabilities are.
But can you tell us a
little bit more about them?
MATT LINTON: Sure.
So essentially, the core
of the vulnerability
is something that has been
latent in CPUs for a long time,
probably close to 20 years.
And it exists in sort
of an efficiency trick
that CPUs have been pulling
to get faster and faster.
What happens is, when you
make a request of the CPU,
and there's a couple of
different potential answers
that may result, sometimes
the CPU will start
executing all of
the instructions
and preparing the results,
so that when you ask it
for the specific
answer you wanted,
it's already got the answer
ready to go and give you,
instead of having to wait
for you to instruct it.
And it turns out
that there are ways
that someone can take
advantage of this
by tricking the CPU
into executing branches
against areas of memory
that would not ordinarily
be accessible to
that person and then
retrieving the results from
the speculated-- they call
it the speculative branches.
PAUL TURNER: Yeah,
I just wanted to add
that I thought the way
that Matt describes this
as tricking the CPU was a really
good way to think about it.
Generally speaking,
the CPU is trying
to do what it thinks should
happen next in your program.
But these attacks
have discovered
new ways of tricking it into
thinking that something should
happen which wouldn't
normally happen
during correct execution.
And the way that that occurs
allows some protection
domains to be bypassed.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So what are things
that are vulnerable to
this type of attack?
MATT LINTON: Well, unlike a
lot of really dangerous attacks
that we've seen before,
sort of the good news first
is that this vulnerability
is a read-only vulnerability.
The really core danger
here is that someone
can trick the CPU
into giving you access
to areas of system memory.
Now that's very
important, because we
have a lot of secrets
in system memory
that you want to keep secret.
You have passwords,
and encryption keys,
and pretty much--
PAUL TURNER: Credit
card numbers.
MATT LINTON: Credit
Any kind of data that you would
normally be processing and care
about will touch memory.
But unlike previous
vulnerabilities
such as Heartbleed, an attacker
can't just reach out, touch
you, and you're done.
There already has to be
away for the attacker
to get onto the system, in order
to exploit this vulnerability
to steal secrets.
Now I don't want
to minimize that.
Because this is the
security industry.
And every good pen tester
knows there are hundreds
of ways to get onto a system.
But it's not once and you're
dead like Heartbleed was.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Well, and I read
that this is impacting personal
computers, mobile phones,
as well as cloud services.
Is that accurate?
PAUL TURNER: Yes.
There's three kind
of major variants
that were discovered
of this attack.
Each of them apply
to various sub cases
of how we use computers today.
Variant 1 is
particularly important
relative to the encapsulation
that we use for things
like JavaScript engines.
Variant 2 is particularly
important with respect
to how we isolate
virtualized machines.
You can think of cloud hosting.
And Variant 3 is also
really important,
in that it's the most direct
way on a consumer device
to steal some of these data
if you are able to arrange
for local execution.
MARK MANDEL: So that's
actually really interesting.
Because I've noticed,
as a consumer,
I've got information
to, like, patch stuff
on my cloud provider, as
well as upgrade my browser.
And I think I've seen
stuff about, like,
upgrading the driver on my GPU.
Is that because there are
just a variety of ways
of taking advantage
of this vulnerability?
PAUL TURNER: Exactly
When you see suggestions
that you should patch
your operating system,
many of those really are
looking at the third variant
where you can attack
local system memory.
Whereas, some of these
other variants that we see,
Variant 1, Variant 2-- commonly
referred to in the media
as Spectre--
they are seeing providers
applying the protections.
You're seeing browsers adding
protections for Variant 1.
You're seeing cloud
providers having protections
for Variant 1 and 2.
But like always in
security, protection
means fixing everything.
And some of those
things are intended
to be employed by consumers.
MELANIE WARRICK: And actually,
when you mentioned Spectre,
I wanted to ask you--
we have heard of the terms
Meltdown and Spectre.
But I also know the
blog post that you guys
provided doesn't necessarily
mention those explicitly.
Matt, you wanted to mention
a little bit about that?
MATT LINTON: Yeah,
so there's been
a decent amount of confusion
out there over Spectre,
and Meltdown and all
of the other variants.
The background behind
this is that there
was a little bit
of a co-discovery
going on but this vulnerability.
Jann Horn from
Google's Project Zero
discovered the
vulnerability and kind
of teased it out into
three distinct variants
that we call
Variant 1, 2, and 3.
A few months later,
another research team,
who was also looking at the
same sort of way to trick CPUs,
discovered the
vulnerabilities, as well.
And they chose to
give them names.
Naming a vulnerability
is something
in the security industry
that is kind of a little bit
preferential.
If you like to name and
logo your vulnerabilities,
you'll do it.
And if you find it to be
uncouth, you don't do it.
So Project Zero did not
choose to give names
to the vulnerabilities.
But the other researchers did.
And so they named them
Spectre for Variants 1 and 2
and Meltdown for Variant 3.
And the reason we ended
up with two names that
covers three vulnerabilities
is that the team that
named Spectre hadn't
discovered all
of the things that
make Variants 1
and 2 unique from one another.
And so they thought
that they had two bugs,
but they really had three.
So we ended up out here
with this naming confusion
where Spectre covers Variant
1, which is most [INAUDIBLE]
in gits and
browsers, and things.
Variant 2, which is
the most exploitable,
as a hypervisor bypass--
and then the whole
separate Variant 3
that they call Meltdown, which
is most exploitable, in terms
of interacting with the
operating system itself.
PAUL TURNER: And
the thing that's
important to know there is where
Matt said Variant 1 and 2 apply
to the browser and
hypervisor and Variant 3
applies to the host
operating system,
for all consumers out there, the
patches for Linux and Windows
are already being included
in those operating systems.
So as long as they upgrade
to use the latest versions,
they will be covered.
MELANIE WARRICK: And that means
MacBooks, as well as those who
use the Linux operating system.
PAUL TURNER: That's correct.
Apple has also published
patches for this one early.
I should have included
in the previous list.
MELANIE WARRICK: No worries.
MARK MANDEL: So this
is interesting, too.
So you said that
the vulnerability
is at a CPU level.
But a lot of these patches are
coming out what are essentially
a software level.
How do these fixes work then?
How does that help people?
PAUL TURNER: The
fundamental thing
that all the fixes are trying to
do is arrange for the execution
to be occurring in a way
so that the tricks that are
being played no longer apply.
In the case of
Meltdown, for example,
you are tricking the
CPU into looking up
memory that it shouldn't
normally be able to access.
And the way that
that was mitigated
was by, instead of using the
regular access protections
on that memory, completely
unmapping it in those contexts
that it should not be accessed.
This meant that, even if
speculative execution were
to try to access it, it
didn't actually know how.
So that's where Variant 1 and 2
have similar kind of approaches
where we're trying to find
ways to restructure the program
control flow so that these
ways that you can influence
or bias when the CPU is
guessing what to do next
are constrained or eliminated.
MATT LINTON: I think there's
a good opportunity here,
too, to talk about how the
words fix and mitigate tend
to be used very intentionally
by security engineers
to mean specific things that
other people might not really
put together.
When we say that a
vulnerability is fixed,
we mean that the actual root
vulnerability is no longer
present in that device.
A lot of the
software mitigations
that you're seeing
come out, these
patches for Windows
and things, they're not
fixing the
vulnerability, so much
as they're mitigating
it by making
it impossible for someone
to take advantage of.
And the analogy that
I like to use for that
is, if you have a
broken window, you
can fix the window by
replacing the window glass.
You can also put a board
over it to mitigate
the hole in the house.
You haven't actually
fixed the window yet.
You've just made the hole in
the house impossible for someone
to come in through.
MELANIE WARRICK: So, in terms of
the fixes and the mitigations,
especially from a standpoint
of the actual processors,
I know at CES, the CEO
of Intel, Brian Krzanich,
had mentioned that they have
basically provided a patch
for 90% of the vulnerabilities
affecting the processes--
or they will be by
the end of the week--
and that they are expecting
to handle the remaining 10
by the end of
January without them
requiring to recall any chips.
Did you guys hear about that?
Did you have any
additional comments
that you wanted to
make on that one?
PAUL TURNER: I would extend the
analogy that Matt just made.
It's clear that, for the
current generation of CPUs,
we will only be able to develop
mitigations and not fixes.
So we're going to be
driving with the boards
on the windows for a long time.
We do expect that, in
future generations,
that these problems will be
fixed at the hardware level.
However, we are also optimistic
that, for all current CPUs,
the mitigations can be
deployed so that we do not
need to replace or
update the hardware.
MELANIE WARRICK: So what
are some of the things
we've done for GCP,
and G Suite, and also
additional internal Google
products and services that
are provided?
PAUL TURNER: There, we've
deployed-- and in many cases,
developed-- the
mitigations that are
being used across the industry.
We have to talk about them
on a case-by-case basis.
Because there are
three variants.
And they each have their
own mitigations or fixes.
However, in all cases, we have
deployed fixes and mitigations
that we believe
cover all the known
classes of the current
vulnerabilities
and ensure that consumer
data remains protected.
MATT LINTON: Yeah,
it's difficult to talk
about this succinctly
in Cloud, especially.
Because this vulnerability
affects so many things.
And Cloud, by nature, affects
people at different levels.
You have software
as a service where
somebody is buying the software
and access to it from us.
Like Drives, Docs, G-mail,
we're providing everything
from the software on down.
And it's very easy for
us to easily just say,
having mitigated our
infrastructure that
runs those products,
and having checked
the software for
their abilities,
we're confident we
protected people there.
But then there's
things like GCE, which
is infrastructure as a service.
People are paying
us to run everything
from the hardware
for them, and manage
scalability, and network,
and all those things.
But they also want to
run their own operating
system inside a container.
It's more complicated
there, because we've
protected all of
the things that they
rely on us to protect for them.
But you can't simply
say, everything's fixed.
Because if a customer runs
their own operating system,
and they're worried
about attacks occurring
from within their OS to
their own data stored in it,
they also have a
little bit of work
to do patching for
these variants.
As well.
PAUL TURNER: A good
example of this
would be a multi-tenant customer
where someone might be doing
re-hosting where they're
hosting from a cloud provider,
such as Google, or
Amazon, or Microsoft.
And then they're internally
kind of releasing that space
to their own uses.
There, the attacks that Matt
just described, in many ways,
they are hosting
provider themselves.
And so the infrastructure
that they've contributed that
runs on top of the underlying
[INAUDIBLE] providers,
such as Google,
Microsoft, Amazon,
that infrastructure
must also be protected.
And that's something
that they must
do in their own
development and plan.
MARK MANDEL: I want to
go back a little bit.
We've been talking sort
of about mitigation,
and fixes-- and that's a really
interesting turn of phrase.
And maybe to extend
the metaphor,
if I have a boarded-up window,
it's nowhere near as pretty as,
say, a fixed window.
But it sort of works
kind of the same.
But maybe I don't
have as nice a house.
If we're talking
about mitigations
for this vulnerability,
are there any sort
of side effects or consequences
of these mitigations that
may end up sort of in the
wild that may be necessary,
but should be stuff that people
should look out for maybe?
PAUL TURNER: That's a
really good question.
Obviously, as you say,
a boarded-up window
is not something that's going
to add value to a property.
So we've been very
careful in how
we develop these mitigations
to try and make sure
that the effects of that
were not observable.
It's definitely true that,
in early versions when
we were kind of prototyping,
developing internally,
we were seeing overhead for many
of these fixes or mitigations.
But as we evolved and
found newer and better ways
to add those
protections, we really
were able to minimize
the overhead that we saw.
In many cases, we actually
see no perceptible overheads
for both our own
and custom workloads
while still providing
these protections.
MATT LINTON: Yeah, we
boarded up the window
with clear plexiglass
that's mostly
indistinguishable
from the old window.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And in terms of GCP,
in regards to what was being
updated and boarded up,
was there any
maintenance downtime?
PAUL TURNER: There was not.
MELANIE WARRICK:
You've described
the guest and host-level
mitigations that
have been taking place.
What do you need
to do in regards
to achieving those
host-level mitigations being
applied to your GCP instances?
PAUL TURNER: So
when you say host
here, what you're
really talking about
is the Google level
mitigations right?
When we say a host, we
mean the infrastructure
that's running the virtual
machines that we're
providing to our users.
There, we're actually
very fortunate,
in that we have technology we
called live migration, which
allows us to move a running
guest between host instances
without requiring a reboot
or otherwise interfering
with the guest.
We were able to actually use
this to transparently deploy
all of our Variant 1 and
Variant 2 mitigations
for our infrastructure with
no customer-reported downtime.
MARK MANDEL: I just
want to hit this point.
People do need to upgrade
their own operating
systems if they're
managing themselves
on something like GCE, or
GKE, or something like that.
PAUL TURNER: Definitely.
As a matter of best
practice, users
should be patching their
own operating system.
The vulnerability
that's most important
there is Variant 3,
as known as Meltdown.
While that attack will
not allow information
to escape between the
hypervisor or our infrastructure
and their operating
system, it is possible
that local attacks from within
their VMs on their own data
may succeed without
those patches.
This is really a matter
of best practice.
MELANIE WARRICK: Something I
keep hearing from people is,
make sure you update
your software.
Whether it's OS, whether
you're on a phone,
whether you're on your
operating system on your laptop,
you always want to make sure,
when you see new patches come
through, to keep updating them.
Do you guys have any
additional recommendations
for best practices
around security?
MATT LINTON: Yeah.
I would say that, anytime
a complex vulnerability
gets discussed, a lot of
people turn to wondering, well,
what should I do about it?
And in security, we kind of
have consistent messaging out
that, most of the
time, the answer
is, keep yourself
updated with software
patches from the
vendor, and make sure
that you're using
two-factor authentication,
and other protective layers on
anything you care deeply about.
And the reason we
always come back
to hammering on that
is, most of the time,
those are the two
most effective things
you can do to
protect yourself not
just against this
vulnerability, but in general
against vulnerabilities
that you know about,
vulnerabilities that
you don't know about,
tomorrow's big discovery
that may come out.
It's all going to end up boiling
down to take care of the things
you're running.
Keep them updated.
And keep your
authentication safe.
PAUL TURNER: It really does
come down to best practice.
The guidelines that
we're proposing here
are uniform within the security
industry, with the idea,
as Matt said, that
they leave you
in the best position for
unknown vulnerabilities
that you may not know about.
And because, often, when
a vulnerability like
this is discovered,
you have to be
able to update your
software quickly.
And if you have not
been keeping up-to-date
with other patches or
security improvements
in the infrastructure, you could
have a large technical debt,
which you might have to mitigate
in a very quick fashion when
something like this comes out.
So those practices
are both preventative
and in making sure
that you can be
as agile as possible in
responding to these issues
when they arise.
MARK MANDEL: So
you're not saying
that there should be
any change in the way
that people are handling
their security best practices.
Really, the
tried-and-true methods
stay the same way they are.
PAUL TURNER: Yes.
Generally speaking,
Variant 3 or Meltdown
is not externally exploitable.
So users are only
really vulnerable
from their own software,
because we've already
patched our exposure to Variant
1 and 2 and their exposure
to Variant 1 and 2 from
our infrastructure.
But again, we really do believe
this is the best practice.
We strongly encourage all of
our users to apply these fixes,
just as they would any
other security [INAUDIBLE]
fix to ensure that,
as new ways to attack
both this and other parts of
the system are discovered,
they can continue
to be protected
as quickly as possible.
MELANIE WARRICK: Can you guys
comment a little bit, too,
on the fact--
I know, in the blog
post and with what
Project Zero released, they were
saying how this is identified,
and then there was
coordinated efforts
to try to do the
fixing and the patching
before it was going to
be announced publicly.
Would you be able to
come in a little bit more
about that process and what
that looks like for coordination
with security?
MATT LINTON: To an extent.
This is one of those things
that is really difficult
and always gets handled on
a case-by-case basis, which
is, you have a giant bug.
You have a lot of work
you need to do to fix it.
Other people you know
also have a lot of work
that need to happen to fix it.
And then you end up
with inter-dependencies.
If Google were to fix
this bug all on our own
without contacting anyone else,
than other operating system
vendors, like Apple
and Microsoft,
wouldn't be protected.
And our users would
be left at risk.
So for something of
this scale, there's
always decisions that need
to be made around, what
other companies need to know?
They need to know to
protect the users.
Do they need to know so
we can protect our users,
so we can protect ourselves?
And sort of an ad
hoc group ends up
forming of people
who are affected, who
believe they have something
to contribute to fix it,
and who are all sort
of giving and receiving
advice and technical
data from one another
to try to put all the
users on the internet in as
good a footing as possible
when we're ready to talk
about the issue without
creating such a large group
that it becomes impossible
to keep the issue contained.
PAUL TURNER: And this really
was an industry-wide effort.
Our own attempts at mitigation
began at the same time
as other industry players.
We weren't trying to provide
a head start for ourselves
or any other advantage.
We really saw this as
an industry-wide problem
that everybody would have
to try to contribute,
both in terms of
finding ways to mitigate
these complicated and
difficult vulnerabilities,
and in making sure
that everyone would
have the chance to
deploy protection
before our disclosure occured.
MATT LINTON: Yeah,
there is a little bit
of a thing called supply chain,
which plays into this a lot,
too.
And supply chain is a
security industry term
which references the fact that
you inherit vulnerabilities
from those you trust to
provide you with things.
And so I'm speaking to you
right now from a MacBook Pro.
I have a supply chain
dependency on Apple
to make sure Apple is
secure if I am to do my job
and keep Google secure.
So in a lot of ways, these sort
of multi-industry partnerships
for something this size are
brought about by necessity
from the fact that the
supply chain forces us all
to adopt at least a little
bit of each other's problems.
MARK MANDEL: You kind of
said something interesting
that I don't know if people
who aren't necessarily
familiar with how security
research sort of goes.
You mentioned that,
up until the point--
I think you said-- that it was
going to be public or it was
going to be shown to
the outside world--
can you talk a little about
how that research process goes,
about finding vulnerabilities,
and then finally making them
public, and the steps that
sort of go through that,
and why those steps exist?
MATT LINTON: Sure.
Those steps exist as
sort of a compromise
that has slowly developed over
time in the IT industry itself.
There are processes
often, these days,
called coordinated disclosure.
And what happens is
a security researcher
finds a vulnerability.
And they report it
to whoever it is
that's actually makes the
product the vulnerability is
in.
And then the vendor
and the researcher
agree upon a period of time in
which the vendor gets a head
start on fixing it to
actually protect people
before the researcher
gets to publish it.
That's in contrast to a behavior
called full disclosure, which
is when researchers
find a vulnerability
and immediately disclose
it to the world.
There's a lot of pros and cons.
And I don't think, probably,
this is a good place
to go into it, unless you
have a couple extra hours.
But I can tell you,
what Project Zero does
is they have a
standard process where
they find a vulnerability.
They notify the maintainer
in whose product
the vulnerability exists.
And they give them 90
days to remediate it
before Project
Zero discloses it.
And if they vendor is able to
remediate it earlier, then they
disclose it earlier in
coordination with the vendor.
And that's sort of
a compromise that
has been reached between the
pros and cons that hit you
when you go full disclosure and
the pros and cons that hit you
when you allow the vendor to
completely control disclosure.
So much of the security
research industry
right now lives in
that compromised zone
of coordinated disclosure
with a defined time period.
MELANIE WARRICK: And this
got released a little earlier
than expected.
Is that right?
PAUL TURNER: Yeah, relative
to what I was saying,
I think the actual
more interesting point
there is this was an example of
a issue that was so pervasive
and affected so many users
that we actually extended
that standard 90-day policy.
Because it was clear that
all of the supply chain level
mitigation that
users would require
would not be possible to
deploy within that window.
So while it's true that,
ultimately, the disclosure
happened a few days before
we had originally intended,
that's really almost
after the fact
relative to the discussions
of how about that time was
being managed.
MATT LINTON: Yeah, so part of
that decision-making process
here, in terms of
disclosure, is there
is a really difficult and
constantly-evolving decision
to be made around, is keeping
this issue on the down low
and giving people time to fix
it better for users and better
for individuals than
telling the world about it?
And in the early
stages of this in,
and in a lot of the
mitigation phases
where everyone had
to develop patches,
we had to performance
test patches,
we had to validate that
they worked, obviously,
keeping it on the down
low and giving people time
to fix it so that, when the
world learned about it everyone
would be prepared to
defend against it,
was better for everyone.
But to a certain
point, people began
to realize that there
was a lot of fixing
going on without a lot
of talking about it.
And they began to put
two and two together.
And very close to the end of
when we were almost prepared
to announce it anyway,
some very clever
people started putting together
public examples of both
the flaw and how you might
use it to attack user data.
And at the point where there's
public examples of someone
being able to
exploit and attack,
that equation is flipped.
It's no longer better for
users and better for people
to have a secret
vulnerability that they
don't know how to defend
against if someone else knows
how to attack.
And so that kind
of forced our hand
into talking about the issue
a little bit earlier than we
were originally planning to.
MELANIE WARRICK:
But you guys are
pretty close to
getting out there
anyways with this information.
MATT LINTON: So close.
PAUL TURNER: I think
the two important things
to be aware of there, it really
was only a matter of days
before the original
disclosure date.
And then the other
thing, calling back
to some of Matt's other
comments, the things
that people were seeing
that were leading them
to ask these questions and start
kind of probing these areas
were those supply chain
level mitigations.
They'd seen Linux deploying
patches from the up down.
They'd seen Microsoft deploying
Apple deployed
patches from up down.
This kind of a
coordinated improvement
doesn't happen by accident.
So that kind of was immediately
setting off people's alarm
bells that something
was going on.
But also, the fact that
all of those vendors
had the time to
develop those patches
was why the disclosure
was delayed.
So that, even though
people were seeing
those things happen
in the supply chain,
they had happened.
So that when
disclosure did occur,
even though it was
actually a few days early,
there were protections
available-- and in many cases,
deployed--
to all of the major
computing platforms
that users depended on.
MARK MANDEL: Well, I
think we're slightly
running out of time here.
But before we wrap
up, is there anything
that you want to make sure you
mention, maybe something we
haven't covered, or if there's
extra information that maybe
people should go look at,
or listen to, or watch
that we haven't managed
to cover so far?
PAUL TURNER: Sure.
I think, generally
speaking, this
was a really good
example of a lot
of people in the industry
coming together to look
at a really tough problem.
And I expect that,
really, in many ways,
we may have opened
Pandora's box here.
There are going to be new
ways to attack these hardware
features.
People are really
going to start looking
at other parts of the CPU and
how they could potentially be
exploited in a similar fashion.
And while that, obviously,
potentially presents
a rich new buoyant vein of
exploits for malicious users,
I'm really encouraged by the
fact that, as an industry,
we seem to be moving
in a good direction
to be able to prevent
them and protect users
to the best of our ability.
MATT LINTON: Yeah, I
don't think I really
have too much to add on
top of what Paul said.
I think there's
a lot of research
in this area that's going to
go forward into the future.
And I think, like it or not, the
next 10 years of the industry
is still going to be a
constant cycle of finding out
new and interesting
things that are
unexpected about our software
and then rolling out ways
to make them behave
the way we originally
thought they would behave.
And if that's not
an integral part
of the computer industry at this
point, I don't know what is.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, great.
Thank you both very much
for joining us and sharing
this information.
We appreciate it.
And that's all we got.
Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks, guys.
MATT LINTON: Yeah, thank you.
Have a good one.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right,
thanks, Matt and Paul.
We appreciate that.
And Mark, I think that's going
to be it for today's episode.
Because we're keeping
it a special episode--
MARK MANDEL: Short.
MELANIE WARRICK: But we'll
definitely do our questions
and cool things
for the next one.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
See you on Wednesday then.
MELANIE WARRICK: See you then.
[MUSIC PLAYING]